was jetzt folgt sind anonym eingereichte
erfahrungen von angestellten bei
finanzunternehmen ein geschäftsführer
hat ein großes bild in seinem büro
hängen und zwar von sich selber
angestellte erzählen dass sie gesehen
haben wir das bild manchmal küsst später
feiert derselbe ceo die rezeptionistin
weil er jemand hübscheren haben möchte
ein anderer geschäftsführer möchte einen
kiss my es klappt einführen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter die
etwas falsch gemacht haben sollen
tatsächlich seinen hintern küssen um
ihren job behalten zu dürfen
in diesen berichten werden ehemalige
oder aktuelle chefs beschuldigt
psychopathen zu sein
das sollen aber nicht nur einzelne
erfahrungen seien sondern teile eines
größeren problems in der chefetage
sitzen vier mal so viele psychopathen
wie im rest der gesellschaft auch allen
masc donald trump oder jeff base kriegen
immer wieder solche diagnosen an den
kopf geworfen
aber ist das alles nur ein großer mythos
oder ist da wirklich etwas dran
um dem ganzen mal auf den grund zu gehen
haben wir mit einem experten gesprochen
und herausgefunden dass die eigentlichen
probleme hier ganz woanders liegen
in der chefetage vorkommen und so
endlich den angestellten wunderbare
mutter schulen führen kann
es gibt eine große britische maß an
mitarbeitern die irgendwas anderes
machen aber nicht unbedingt das was
schön wäre ich finde psychologie ein
wahnsinnig spannendes feld und vor allem
für dieses video hier mussten wir es
durch einige bücher aus der
fachliteratur wälzen teilweise weiß man
da aber gar nicht wo man anfangen soll
aber die gute nachricht ist wenn ihr so
viel wie möglich in so kurzer zeit wie
möglich über ein thema lernen wollt dann
ist blinkt ist etwas für euch denn
blinkt ist bricht lange bücher auf das
wesentliche herunter und teilt euch die
wichtigsten aussagen der bücher in
einzelne blinkx auf es gibt über 3000
sachbücher im angebot gibt der ratgeber
klassiker bestseller aus über 25
kategorien wie wissenschaft
produktivität und psychologie da gibt es
zum beispiel psychopathen von kevin
daten hier lernt ihr was psychopathen
ausmacht und wie sie erfolgreich werden
und mit blink ist könnt ihr jetzt in nur
16 minuten lesen
jeden monat kommen ungefähr 40 15
minütige blinkx hinzu und wenn ihr dann
doch mal tiefer in ein buch einsteigen
wollte dann findet ihr inzwischen auch
ganze hörbücher auf blinkt ist im moment
gibt es eine aktion mit der 25 prozent
auf ein jahres abo blinkt es premium
sparen könnt dafür müsst ihr nur auf
blickpunkt de / doktor watson gehen um
ein abo abzuschließen und damit auch
gleichzeitig unseren kanal zu
unterstützen
und wenn ihr euch noch nicht so ganz
sicher sein ob das wirklich was für euch
ist ihr könnt es ohne probleme kostenlos
sieben tage lang testen
danke an brink ist für die unterstützung
bei diesem video risiken eingehen
impulsiv und furchtlos sein das klingt
nach dem stereotypischen business mogul
tatsächlich sind es aber ein paar der
merkmale die man psychopathen zuschreibt
wie passt das zusammen man geht davon
aus dass man bei 1 prozent unserer
gesellschaft von psychopathen reden kann
und wir meinen hier nicht die
umgangssprachliche psychos dass man sich
mal eben so in der bahn an den kopf
wirft sondern wirklich von der diagnose
psychopathie und eines direkt vorweg ja
in der business-welt soll diese zahl um
einiges höher sein
es gibt aber studien dijon hinweisen
dass wenn sie in der chefetage unterwegs
sind dass sie dort vier prozent also das
vierfache psychopathen
dort treffen was natürlich schon ein
hinweis darauf ist ja dass solche
dunklen persönlichkeiten solche lieder
wie ist dann heißt ja schon auf eine
chefetage sitzen psychopathie ist ein
teil davon was experten als die dunkle
triade bezeichnung psychopathie nazismus
und machiavellis muss obwohl es schon
große unterschiede zwischen den drei
persönlichkeitsmerkmalen gibt haben sie
ein paar sachen gemeinsam in der mitte
findet sich ein selbstsüchtiger
emotional kalter manipulativer mensch
aber wie wird man mit dunklen
persönlichkeitszüge erfolgreich alle
drei teile verbindet eine exzessive
motivation nach dominanz narzissten
sehen sich nach sozialer power
psychopathen benutzen ihr umfeld
aggressiv zum eigenen vorteil so
zumindest auf dem papier
in der praxis gibt es aber noch sehr
wenige studien dazu wie das ganze in der
arbeitswelt wirklich stattfindet
zumindest ein teil der dunklen triade
sticht aber heraus und das ist nicht die
psychopathie sondern narzissmus das
liegt unter anderem daran dass nazismus
seinen zwei kollegen der dunkle triade
in einem punkt voraus ist nazismus kann
sich positiv auf soziale skills
auswirken
bei machiavellis muss ist das oft
negativ und bei psychopathie sowohl
positiv als auch negativ
rassismus ist so etwas wie die sozialste
ausführung der dunklen persönlichkeiten
narzissten empfinden sich selbst als
grandios und stellen ihre eigenen
interessen über alles andere das alleine
kann schon unangenehm sein
aber wenn man sich an einer zyste über
einen rassisten in den weg stellt man
zeigt sich eine weitere facette dann
haben solche menschen schwierigkeiten
ihre emotionen und ihr verhalten zu
kontrollieren und zeigen häufig
aggressive reaktionen
kombiniert man das dann aber mit hohen
sozialen skills scheint sich das
beruflich tatsächlich auszuzahlen
man steigt schneller die karriereleiter
auf so eine dominanz setzen wir schnell
mit guter leistungen gleich auch wenn es
vielleicht gar keine gute leistung gibt
als gesellschaft belohnen wir eben mut
und tatendrang
aber wie lange anfänglich finden dass
auch ihre untergebenen dann auch relativ
toll aber es gibt studien die zeigen
dass dieser dieser erste positive
eindruck und ist ganz häufig bei
narzissmus bewusster ein positiver
erster eine relativ schnell verpufft
sobald angestellte die möglichkeit haben
die negativen eigenschaften ihres ihrer
führungsperson zu sehen also dass die
arroganz aber auch die den selbstbezug
und dass dann die diese einschätzung
auch das ist total die effektive
führungsperson dass das dann runter geht
ok menschen die hohe ausprägungen auf
der dunklen triade und vor allem
nazismus haben können besonders schnell
erfolgreich werden
und oben angekommen können sie für
verdammt unangenehme stimmung sorgen
aber die gute nachricht ist folgende sie
haben dass laut studien schwer
auch in diesen stellen zu bleiben
zumindest je nach firma aber dazu kommen
wir gleich noch mal
jetzt gibt es aber eine schlussfolgerung
hier wird auf gar keinen fall aus diesem
video mitnehmen sollte
und die hat etwas mit den geschichten
vom anfang des videos zu tun denn das
sind subjektive erfahrungen und keine
echten diagnosen und das zeigt ein
großes problem wenn es um rassismus oder
psychopathie geht viele menschen wissen
nicht dass sich beides auf einem
spektrum befindet und da gibt es
natürlich niedrige mittlere und auch
sehr hohe ausprägungen
das ist genauso wie mit körpergrößen
manche menschen klein manche mir schon
groß aber jeder mensch hat eine
körpergröße ich kann nicht sagen ich
habe keine körpergröße
genauso wenig kann man sagen ich habe
keine nazismus jeder mensch ist etwas
narzisstisch und je extremer jemand auf
dem spektrum aus schlägt desto eher kann
man von einer krankheit reden
rassismus ist immer in meinem gefühl das
was die anderen haben
also man dann natürlich gerne an und
dann wird das oft auch soll es stieg
marvel nutzt und klar wenn wir menschen
treffen die besonders unangenehm oder
dominanz
dann ist es immer einfach zu sagen mein
chef ist krank ist ein totaler
psychopath oder platz ist
hierbei sollten wir aber vorsichtig sein
und uns erst einmal fragen was meine ich
eigentlich wenn ich nazis muss sage sehe
ich narzissmus als einen ausdruck der
persönlichkeit wie ihn alle menschen in
verschiedenen ausprägungen haben also
auch du und ich oder meine ich dass im
sinne einer krankheit die entweder
vorliegt oder nicht diese unterscheidung
ist wichtig wir alle liegen irgendwo auf
dem nazismus spektrum und andere
menschen narzisstisch zu finden ist
total okay vor allem wenn tatsächlich
entsprechende verhaltensweisen gezeigt
werden wir können ja auch von anderen
leuten als narzisstisch eingeschätzt
werden aber andere menschen per
ferndiagnose eine krankheit zu sprechen
also zu sagen dass die sophie narzissmus
haben dass sie krank sind das ist
unethisch
denn damit bricht man die roboter wurde
diese regel besagt keine ferndiagnosen
es ist einfach unfair menschen mal eben
eine wirklich knallharte diagnose an den
kopf zu werfen ohne dass diese diagnose
nach dem richtigen vorschriften und von
den richtigen menschen gemacht wurde
ähnliche dinge sieht man zum beispiel
wenn es um donald trump oder jeff pacers
geht vielleicht sind das wirklich
unangenehme menschen aber für eine
diagnose braucht man expertinnen und
experten die befassten sich dann
intensiv mit einem menschen und können
danach dann entscheiden ob die werte für
nazismus oder psychopathie so hoch sind
dass man von narzissten oder
psychopathen im sinne einer krankheit
sprechen kann
gehen wir aber mal davon aus die
geschichten vom anfang würden wirklich
zu einer diagnose führen
dann sind wir direkt beim nächsten
problemen denn das sagt ja eigentlich
mehr über die firma aus als über den
bösen chef der krank ist immerhin müssen
so leute erst mal eingestellt oder
befördert werden bevor sie schaden
anrichten können
chef wird man nicht von alleine es
braucht also da müsste man ja schon auch
mal gucken dass das unternehmen daran
arbeitet bestimmte 19 nicht mehr in
führungspositionen kommen zu lassen also
nicht nur select in kriterien
festzulegen was muss eine person
mitbringen sondern auch selected
kriterien also was darf eine person
nicht mitbringen ich meine denkt mal
drüber nach bewerbungsgespräche sind
quasi das einzige mal dass unternehmen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter auf
herz und nieren prüft
und dabei können wir daher noch gar
nicht wissen wie sich einen azubi mal in
zehn 20 30 jahren als chef schlagen wird
idealerweise gibt es eine wiederkehrende
bewertung wenn es zum beispiel eine neue
stelle mit mehr verantwortung gibt dann
kann man schlecht erkennen dass der
fleißige azubi besser nicht das
management in die hand nimmt weil er
nicht nur fleißig ist sondern auch sehr
fleißig die ellenbogen ausfährt und
seine kolleginnen und kollegen sabotiert
um selbst besser dazustehen
die firmenkultur bestimmt maßgeblich ob
es menschen mit persönlichkeitsmerkmalen
der dunklen triade überhaupt erst weit
schaffen können noch interessanter finde
ich jedoch dass die firmenkultur auch
bestimmen kann wie sehr nazismus oder
psychopathie ausgelebt werden dann auch
empirische studien die zeigen dass
selbst leute die eine hohe ausprägung
dieser dunklen triade haben also
psychopathie narzissmus und
materialismus dass die weniger
kontraproduktives arbeitsverhalten
zeigen wenn sie sich in ihren
organisationen wertgeschätzt fühlen und
den eindruck haben dass da so ethische
unternehmenskultur da ist also den
eindruck haben da ist jemand um ein wohl
besorgt was macht man also um mit
dunklen persönlichkeitseigenschaften in
der chefetage umzugehen
in erster linie überlässt man die
diagnose einer psychischen störung bitte
den profis eine amateur diagnose hilft
mir vielleicht ein bisschen dampf
abzulassen wird dem chef aber
wahrscheinlich überhaupt nicht gefallen
auf der arbeit hilft es sich zu
vernetzen und gemeinsam über offizielle
wege zu versuchen auf das problem
aufmerksam zu machen
am besten dokumentiert man auch
grenzverletzungen vom chef oder der
chefin
wichtig ist auch dass sie in jedem fall
die eigene gesundheit über die arbeit
stellt wenn du stark unter unethischem
verhalten oder belästigungen auf der
arbeit leidest dann wenn du dich bitte
an die telefonseelsorge die nummer
findet ihr unten in der video
beschreibung dort arbeiten
deutschlandweit mehrere tausend menschen
die zwar keine therapie ersetzen können
aber ich helfen können den ersten
schritt zu gehen und auch einfach mal
zuhören
langfristig müssen wir als gesellschaft
aber auch vor allem die wirtschaft eine
umgebung schaffen in der menschen und
ihre arbeit wertgeschätzt werden
das machen viele unternehmen so manche
wollen das aber vielleicht auch nicht
es gibt immer noch sehr traditionell
geführte unternehmen bis hin zu ganzen
branchen die auf strengen hierarchien
und ganz klaren machtstrukturen aufbauen
und das krasse ist für manche
situationen kann es tatsächlich helfen
ein bisschen narzissmus in der chefetage
zu haben
studien haben gezeigt dass besonders in
krisenzeiten ein bisschen unethische
führung nützlich sein kann
zumindest für den gewinn des
unternehmens wie eben schon mal erwähnen
sind solche effekte aber meistens nicht
von dauer langfristig leiden
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter unter
solchen leuten und sowieso erfolgt nur
am gewinn zu messen halte ich persönlich
für falsch wie hier sind ja auch eine
firma trend itu eine produktionsfirma
und bei uns sind langfristigkeit und
nachhaltigkeit sehr wichtige faktoren
auf die wir viel wert legen wir wollen
keine schnellen gewinne machen wir
wollen nicht wachsen wir wollen nicht an
die börse
wir wollen coole videos produzieren wir
wollen die welt ein bisschen schlauer
machen und vor allem wollen wir dazu
machen dass wir das auch noch in vielen
vielen jahren tun können
wir wollen es also nicht zu tode
arbeiten nachhaltigkeit im weitesten
sinn sozusagen
aber uns ist natürlich auch um
nachhaltigkeit im ökologischen sinne
wichtig deswegen haben wir mal ein video
produziert wie man im klassischen
wirtschaftsmodell anders denken kann und
nachhaltig ökologisch sinnvoll
wirtschaften kann
das könnt ihr euch hier ansehen gerne da
klicken ansonsten immer vielen dank fürs
zuschauen und bleibt neugierig